In a subscription model the customer
pays your required price
to have access to the product.
Subscription provides
an excellent opportunity
to create continued revenue streams
which is wonderful because the lifetime
value of our users will be higher.
>> And when users purchase
subscriptions in your Android Apps,
Google Play handles all
the check-out details for you.
If you have an iOS App,
the Apple store also does the same.
In other words,
you don't have to directly process
any financial transactions.
This insures a consistent and
familiar purchase flow and
improves user experience.
It also causes you a lot less headache.
>> Some tips for using this model.
It is recommended to use
a free trial subscription
to allow users to explore
the app first and see the value.
You could set a time limit or
any other limit that fit your scenario.
For example, Dropbox will limit the
space you could use on their free tier.
Due to some direct
carrier billing limits,
we also recommend monthly subscription.
Annual subscription may exceed limits,
causing the purchase to be blocked.